oh okay we're get rid of your life say
one and we live hi everybody we are live
with the weekly pool and as usual I am
Betty the comic story and that is rob
from marvel explained that is Sal from
TV little house that is our mean from
comic book cast and that is Bobby hill
from the what's that show it's on the
Army has known these people for just
like a little bit he's already turned
them against and this week guys I have
no comic books to show you but I am
gonna rub it in everyone's face I got
the rare army bows alright guys as usual
welcome to the weekly poll we do this
every week for those of you guys who are
just now joining us for the first time
it is every week on Tuesdays at 6 p.m.
right now it is live on Rob's channel
over here at Marvel explained but as of
next week the weekly pull dotnet will be
live and this will be broadcast on
Twitch so make sure you guys follow us
on twitch twitch comm or twitch TV
whatever twitch push that TV back slash
the weekly poll we will have official
links up and everything so you don't the
guess but I'm just letting you all know
ahead of time and this week we are
joined by the comic book cast you guys
want to say hello for the record guys
I'm sure like everyone knows so the
comic book cast is they are the old hats
on the comic book YouTube scene they've
been here longer than dirt I think when
YouTube started they were like day two
we're making the comic book cast
they've been here forever but if you
don't know who they are they literally
cover everything comics movies TV shows
comic books video games about the comic
books I've seen things on there where
they're playing Minecraft while chatting
about comic books and being in comic
book costumes they just do it all so if
you don't know who they are you
definitely should know who they are and
it's located at youtube.com backslash
comic book cast - i'm gonna breathe now
someone else take over can we if I may
can we just really quick before we start
off with the comics can I ask about the
- yes
because our second Channel and here's
the thing apparently at some point when
I originally conceived comic book cast I
made a comic book cast YouTube and then
I lost the password and the Economist I
- and I contacted YouTube and they're a
customer service you know how that goes
oh my god it was easier to just add a
2bic we're 2.0 and okay I just I really
legitimately just assumed some jackass
got comic book cast and then never did
anything with it and you're like I've
been there myself a creative channel I
had it all set up forgot the password
nope
that's into that people will remember as
people who you know would the thing is
the comic book cast in our earliest form
back when it was the ex vor PSM channel
it was even called comic-book caster
Richie we predate variant he started
comic book has to write around the same
time era started Barrett we were
actually neck and neck in subs for a
little bit and then he overtook us cuz
he's like everybody like the reason I
started you know how everybody was doing
comic book reviews and stay sit here and
they tell you about it I was like what
if I just show people panel when I say
we'll get the emotion in Miles Morales
eyes cuz no one did that up to that
point and you know people right that's
actually really smart I was like okay so
uh you know what guys why don't we look
from your words the people who don't
know who comic book cast is just like I
mean I've explained a little bit you
guys have anything else you want to say
about it you want to like this we always
do an opening plug for you for the guest
and we always do an end plug so write
one of our most popular shows we're
doing right now is comic lash which of
course I mean everyone does a versus
show but we kind of do it a little
differently is that our mean will make
his case for a Marvel character I will
make my case for a DC character and then
we let the fans vote is what we do you
know during that short run I mean like
you know everybody gives you their stats
we say nothing is off the table
so you know what I'm gonna defense
century I can order mention everything
is better so if century at some point
becomes a cyborg eating planet that's
good to be talking every alternate
reality we put everything in the pot
because
the way we figured it people are gonna
argue about this stuff non-stop anyway
so we're like look we're taking all
accountability off ourselves so
everything is everything is on the table
everything is go and you the fan just
saw we used to do the same thing when we
first first launched the weekly poll we
actually had a segment we called it a
pre-show and this is the when I put it
up on my channel and we would debate
like we would debate on based on our
knowledge who would win a contest and
I'm just more imaginative than these two
boneheads so I really an idea it was it
was almost an Elsa required you to
really be on your feet and there was
something was a degree of role-playing
involved we had betrayed the character
or at least like lie like it was very
D&D where it's like wow spider-man's
gonna leap off the wall and I was really
really fascinating I was really excited
to be a part of it and I literally
couldn't do it I was like I was like oh
sorry good I was gonna say and you
rolled your d20 yes I can do that like
in that kind of setting but in the live
like describing especially when it comes
to I don't know why but like I can be
like my Dragonborn launches his Lance of
Erie no problem when I'm talking about
like spider-man fighting against John
Paul Valley Batman I'm like it just
feels really silly we're guys who read
comic books for a living and you're
saying that discussing that is silly
well I think this I think described it
feels like no I know these characters
and they wouldn't do that like it's it
was weird but uh but I feel like I
really draw the ball there I'm like no
this is this is a good idea but yeah
like it in honesty it's like shouldn't
every superhero fight and the same ways
like and then the two heroes being hero
sat down and discussed their issues
right ran into we actually had one
episode where it was Batman versus
Captain America oh and we were like we
were like we initiate it and we're like
both of these guys would just be like
alright let's talk you look like a good
guy so uh I'm not gonna lie guys we
planned this entire thing out we plan to
have comic book cast on here and we
didn't think of the topic because I'm
looking at our list and I'm like we
didn't think of the topic
so on so you know what the first topic
we were discussing beforehand and I want
to bring up with the comic at
how do you guys feel about spider-man
2099 being shut down for a secret Wars
2099 I'm actually a really big fan of
the book I know our meaning I go back
and forth on this one a lot I like what
Peter David's doing in that book and
even more so I liked what he was doing
in all new X Factor because he tied
those together and he tied that together
with an older story about the future and
perfect and the maestro and everything
from like oh man this is building up to
something that I'm like oh really
oh you're shutting it down damn it c41
like I'm actually excited but to me it's
the excitement comes from I'm hoping
they build up into it and you know why
they're in there if it's a natural
progression then it's like okay here
they come to this end of this you know
and then they go over to sycamores and
make sense it's a story that carries
through I'm perfectly fine if it's just
one of those things where they cut it
they appear Secret Wars in like three
months later or whatever it continues
I'm gonna feel really cheated out of it
you like so I have to see how it plays
out before I actually you know before we
say yay or nay honestly man I think
that's what they'll do I think it'll
just be like a little like spider for
spider-man 2099 I'll just come to a
screeching halt and it'll just $20 that
writer just can't catch a break candy
because the same thing with x-factor
where it's just like hey mr. snow and
I'm from the future acting all this
other stuff yeah yeah mutants whatever I
I personally think that's gonna happen
cuz spider-man 2099 as much as it looks
like they just gonna cancel it I think
it's gonna come back under the new
timeline because they set up way too
much stuff for it to just go away out we
had like five issues of setting up
Miguel O'Hara in like the present day
his cast his characters everyone is with
them then he just immediately got ripped
out of that and put into the
spider-verse event and now he's gonna be
ended that makes no sense a setup for
nothing
that felt really weak like Miguel O'Hara
being put into the present like that was
a neat idea but then spider-verse like
wrapping him up at first I'm like cool
that totally fits in I'm sure there's a
brilliantly orchestrated reason why like
Miguel O'Hara had to be in the present
for spider-verse no see I'm glad you say
that because that's what me and Joel go
back and forth about cuz I love 2099 and
I want to see him doing more in that
universe
but yeah hey come when you put him in
the same universe as P and I'm like well
it's the same universe he's just doing
his thing when his few on you know other
powers I'm like it's you know it leaves
me like more I want more but I'm getting
a less at the same time yeah Thursday's
there's a world of difference between
the 2099 of like 1996 and 2099 that like
Marvel's been trying to give us over the
last decade and trying really hard to is
the thing I'm storm which was like what
is this like with like ultimate Miguel
O'Hara and that was but I was yeah I had
hope for the title when they said the
Peter David was down but back on it I
was like man like if he's gonna come up
with some way to get Miguel O'Hara back
into 2099 and we're gonna have to and
we're just gonna pick up right where it
left off but no I don't know it's it's I
don't think it's coming back like I
think that's it you really think I mean
like the weird thing I find about the
spider-man tunnels in general and I'm a
huge fan of the spider-man tunnels I
always get every single one of them but
it feels like for the last six months
they've just been starting and stopping
like non-stop likes they just they
pretty much ended agent venom Scarlet
Spider and now they're just like let's
try this nope let's try this no let's
try this no yeah oh I think like what
for issues then this cancelled yeah silk
and its spider-gwen all gonna be coming
really close like well isn't this gonna
likely Cheech others fan base and Spider
Woman that has not gotten off to a good
start at all like starting her in spite
of burst that's just bad it was I'm not
crazy about the writing she's she's just
really mean and I'm likeable she is it I
agree with you now what it's like at
least spider-man 2099 got a good start
like we establish the characters who he
is whatever
Spider Woman literally issue one is
picking light up out of an amazing
spider-man issue like there's like if
you don't know who Jessica drew is
you're not gonna start knowing now like
the thing is like she's not really a
spider-man character like she is like
totally devoid of that universe it's
only when they have a spider event like
Grimm hunter this that like she's
dragged into it and it'd be great for
her to be like to have some kind of like
non role in that where she's like no I
have nothing to do with Peter Parker or
your stupid totems
like I got my powers totally differently
and I'm a spy and I do like I'm kidding
with Hydra and shield and like not this
what's that great joke and Ultimate
Alliance when you can talk to Spider
Woman in the game and she's like look
I'm not Peter Parker's girlfriend I'm
not you know his sister that he gave a
blood transfusion on my own character
yes I thought Spider Woman leave me
alone well they even make a joke about
that in spider-verse where like a whole
bunch of crap happens if she makes a
little comment up this is why we never
team up it always goes back yeah but
that's it's really like number two I
think or whatever it is
machines yes she's like with more loon
like which was kind of a kind of a weird
thing I don't understand why Marvel did
that where they were like hey like we
have more loon hunting like all these
totems and killing off all these spiders
except for that one he's banging future
sex slave well I mean the Weaver says
that he planned that something that
because that made sense like I agree I
was even asking that question myself and
told we get to the Weaver and the
weavers like I've made this happen I did
you not wonder how that happened cuz
you're right like yeah I want to kill
all the spider people but that one that
was hot my first question and the
weavers like well I've been subtly
manipulating things and it's like okay
you know what like this is just Marvel
being lazy this is just way out for like
this stuff so let's just say the
Weaver's been manipulating yes you know
what invent the Reaver and then make him
do that spider versus that we've seen in
loom world we've seen in the inheritors
universe that characters exist like
actual spider-man characters like Mary
Jane and like Robbie and all these other
characters exist and I kept waiting like
oh well they're gonna play a part aren't
they where they're gonna be like the
resistance movement against the
inheritors yeah and then nothing happens
with them how spider-woman Dex alternate
universe Mary Jane does even try to talk
to my hey she could have helped you may
be right yeah they you know they're not
on the team of like the more lunatics
like it's not gonna can take credit for
that that's one of my commenters said
that who's reading this and right you
know I'm a fan of obviously Captain
America's like number one Marvel hero
and I'm reading battleworld I'm like
well I see the jack
you know spider-man and his spider mech
shows up but can we have a side issue to
that so I can see what Japanese Captain
America and his Mac look like for some
of that and like the universe as big as
it is it's really contained to you know
just spider-man if this is Marvel I was
expecting them to just throw money you
know big no-no here's all the
explanations cuz you know you're gonna
buy them I'm like yes I am right that's
that actually would have been amazing I
because they've even shown like Oh Iron
Man on loon world is evil you know he
right Hawkeye is evil and join in it so
we've seen certain ones of them so yeah
I mean and you know what you're right
because they've done all these like
spin-off issues all these like here's
six more stories of spider people and
here's all this stuff and we've barely
seen anything that could've come out
these ones didn't even show up early
they just popped out we've got all the
Japanese people konichiwa
they milked Spider Island they had like
you know Power Man and Iron Fist fighter
like I'm surprised there's no spider
verse cast america spider-verse Iron Man
spider verse defenders fighter furs
anything like I guess because like it
the spider verse event and what is
happening in New Avengers with like the
with the incursions and everything are
in total opposition with each other with
the exception of like one reference to
it where I think it's a the Brian
Braddock universe they're like oh the
incursions are happening and this other
thing that's what I said like in in the
last podcast that's why I said it needed
like what they needed to do was this
alright
it didn't even have to be like a Phi the
issue of venom spider versus that tied
into the incursions all that had to
happen was like silk was jumping through
worlds and then she jumps through one
world where like the black priests are
killing everybody
yeah or the yeah and then and then just
like leave the black swans yeah that
would been awesome yeah I mean that's
that's that's all it needed to be but
seemed like like elements here's what
here's what I didn't like about one of
these I did like about spider-verse a
lot of the cool stuff they just didn't
do anything with like when Seok goes to
that world is totally desolated by
nuclear fallout and everybody gets there
and yeah they go to Ezekiel's bunker and
then like Uncle Ben is in there and so
they're like oh my god how did the world
get this way he was like well it has
something to do with Doctor Octopus
something to switch over to something
else no time an issue where we see that
adventure like I'm glad you said that
cuz this reminded me of my problem with
the Star Wars prequels where they're
like hey and again remember that pit of
gundarks not gonna mention her tell you
about I'm like what why you mention it X
I have no point of reference and I'm
like yeah they're expecting me to you
know Uncle Ben's world was changed I'm
supposed to feel emotional I'm like cool
but you haven't showed me why or how or
anything so like it's just like this
mute feeling I get throughout the issues
don't get me wrong I'm enjoying reading
it but I wish there was more expanded to
it which there sadly isn't so the big
issue with the spider-verse in general
as the entire series is nothing but
jokes and red herrings to things that
you'll never find out how it happened I
love it because I love the joking nature
of it but when you take when you
actually take out all the jokes in the
spider-man humor and basically them just
slapping it in the face the fact that
spider-man that has had been in so many
different things you really have a very
very very shallow store it doesn't go
anywhere oh they're just they're going
here and then they go here and then they
go there that's it like I was gonna say
that's okay because eventually they're
gonna put out tales from the spider
verse you know what Secret Wars wasn't
happening I would be convinced that's
something they're gonna do and they
might just do it anyway just display but
I was thinking like with the Secret Wars
thing like that's that's been kind of
serie Wars is kind of like that's been
this big elephant in the room when it
comes to any Marvel book right now like
like Thor we picked up Thor number four
were talked about Thor and this is
tangentially related so Thor number four
like Thor and Odin son like meat and
we're like okay cool like we're
establishing female Thor as the proper
Thor until secret Wars yeah that's my
thing too like like yeah the new Thor
and yo Sam Wilson Captain America it's
like well this is great and a new status
quo change or everything but you're
gonna change it back aren't you I don't
even a year like yeah yeah I mean and
it's not even those two like we have
superior Iron Man
evil iron man who's trying to mess in
the world that's gonna catch it we all
we all know that one oh yeah in fact you
know I mean just like all the major
books are going in that direction the
fact that name war has been supposedly
killed that's gonna change yeah
neighbors been killed guys the ultimate
universe is going to end but all your
favorites are gonna pop up in the
mainstream you know don't worry about
that you know if I could if unless we
were still talking about unless we want
to keep staying on the on the spider
force topic I want to toss out a
question for the panel here and that
being what with the ultimate universe
and the 616 universe colliding and we're
going to see something happen number one
do you think we're gonna see character
merging and if so yep is that something
you want to see here's exactly what I
think is gonna happen like I think and
here's this is how I think it's all
gonna turn out now I think there are
gonna be some people who are you know
his spewed hits and some folks are gonna
be excited at the end of all this Peter
Parker's gonna die they're gonna kill
him off and Miles Morales is gonna take
his place and I see I've got a different
idea of that though my cat my theory is
and I want to get your guy's opinion to
this because I've been hearing the
rumors of this that Marvel is and I've
been seeing this mentioned multiple
times in multiple locations now there's
no concrete evidence of it but that
Marvel is planning to take properties
that they don't own the rights to and
they're just gonna shuffle them off to
their own universes so Peter Parker
spider-man will continue on but he won't
be in six one six cuz marble can't mess
with him so that way he doesn't affect
any more events and they don't have to
worry about him
with this new universe or this new this
new Reaper there's only one universe
like that's that's their main yeah
planet is like the one continuity there
are no other Avenue ities I mean I get
what you're saying - you know what
you're saying with the one universe but
do you think it's viable for them to
actually do that because look let's not
pretend I know as much as the writers
like to say it they're like well the
movies don't influence the comics yeah
all that Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
what you're saying you know to me the
way I feel it's like they put spider-man
and Miles Morales gonna be in there I
feel like they're gonna restore his
marriage and be a spider-man
is going to tour all these younger
people Miles Morales is the new
spider-man in six months six Peter
Parker's married he has his kid back
he's gonna live out a successful wife
until the next Marvel movie spider-man
reboot whether you keep them old you
keep them married you keep them
semi-retired and that's a nice little
middle finger to the young hip trendy
Amazing Spider make a lot of one more
day people freak the hell out this is
very difficult with five of us did not
talk over each other but I will say this
like as far as the merging is go I think
we're probably gonna like if they do
that if like they were like hey ultimate
and like whatever works better over here
we're gonna put over here like for
example since we were talking about
spider-man I think they're going to
merge Aunt May's we're gonna get the
younger cooler way better character
here's the issue with the theory that
they're gonna do one universe I can tell
you definitively
that is not going down that way now
because because what they will do is in
the six one six yes this is the one
universe but the fact the matter is the
Disney XD line is an established
secondary universe the the video games
are an established secondary universe
the movie universe is an established
secondary universe those are all going
to stay that way they're not going to be
merged in and since right off the bat
we're going to have all of these other
universes still happening will initially
launch with six one six and then slowly
but surely just like after every DC
crisis that start to see inclinations of
other universes still existing little
references this one continuity is not
gonna last there's no way it could
because one continuities never last
no people loved it last like a decade of
alternate realities like people loved
like people have the idea like what
happens if all the superheroes just die
in some massive explosion then what
happens next like what happens if Doctor
Doom conquers the world like singer
Morris number 12 yeah exactly like what
are people gonna do I mean yeah well
Secret Wars he just like like
manipulated molecule man and was like
yeah like kill everybody for he blew up
everybody
but yeah I mean you could even say
though for the faux no the comic books
are completely separate sewed in the
movies yes they're established separate
but they're not but if they've ruined
that because it's spider-verse they
referenced the movie spider-man meaning
that those universes are in the mix yeah
that's like you know what I was saying I
made a theory video about that saying
well the movie Avengers appear in secret
Wars and my theory behind it was you go
read original sin zero one of watch or
stand out with Nova and they pan up in
the panel's Robert Downey jr. Iron Man
is clearly represented next to Captain
America Chris Evans it's clear as day
that they exist I'm like do they merge
these universes to say hey guys
everything from the movies stays in but
now look at all this other things we got
because I really feel like they're
trying to simplify it for people cuz you
know my wife used to read comics and she
tries to pick up what I'm reading now
and I'm like oh let me tell you where
magneto is at her eyes glazed over she
just goes yeah whatever and walks away
I'm like yeah that makes sense you know
like and then people in the chatter
talking about Franklin Richards dying
like he died off panels our chat is
blowing up right now everyone's saying
all Franklin Richards are gonna fix it I
just kind of let him like if you read
the latest New Avengers 2 panels he died
it was an off panel death there's no way
that Marvel is going to use a old like
people are expecting Beyonder to show up
and be like no Clause of it no we have a
whole race of beyonders yeah exactly
we're not gonna get Franklin Richards
being the like snowglobe well just a
kid's ending we're not yes you made me
look up that show and research that will
have gone down the rabbit hole isn't it
you know what's funny my god whatever
the guy who plays munches from Richard
Belzer Richard Belzer because he refuses
to play anyone but detective munch yeah
he is in like seven different shows that
all are but then now part of that
universe including like x-files and
stuff and Lord org but anyway yes so go
down the rabbit hole you'll find all
that's good but no they're not gonna
make it all Franklin Richards fault
the bureau's not gonna show up and fix
it all they're gonna make it really
accessible they're gonna make it a
character that you know
to make it like Iron Man or something
something annoyingly simple so that the
average reader on free comic book day
will pick up that book read it and enjoy
it and then not be confused and annoyed
at the end of it like they were in like
infinity okay starts with this whole
event yeah they're kicking it off the
others drawing interest in but see like
later
see there's things you can look at
though that'll tell you what direction
it's going in like Jonathan Hickman they
said that this row boom along guy is
someone we've never seen before he's a
brand new character sure yeah sure now
my personal opinion I think it's a brand
new character to the earth-616
continuity another version of another
character of a character that we've
already seen is all it is it's gonna be
a revamp it's gonna be like an evil
Franklin Richards or something like that
I don't know but what what if what if it
is the master villain in the next
Avengers movie what is that doing
wouldn't that be what what like in the
New Avengers movie Ultron comes by and
they get rid of him by sending him
through a dimension and he just goes to
town he becomes robbed ooh-la-la but but
when they meet up it's just Ultron I
don't know either way I mean later
they're killing off the Fantastic Four
you know they have I mean they killed
off Franklin Richards which is which was
in a lot of ways like we said like that
that would be their way of fixing the
continuity [ __ ] which is like oh my
god I don't like what's going on here
and just snaps his fingers and it all
gets fixed and it all goes away you know
they're killing off characters like they
killed off Wolverine they killed off
characters they're not getting the movie
rights to I don't you shuffling them off
to a different reality I see them
getting rid of them and I think they're
gonna kill off like Peter Peter Parker's
been around for what like if you look at
comics as a pop culture icon which is
what comics have become the three big
ones you will see everywhere around the
world and they are recognizable no
matter what our Batman Superman is
spider-man yes spider-man is the one
worldwide recognizable pop-culture
figure since the 60s now I mean Captain
America Iron Man all never getting
bigger but they are nowhere near the
level of spider-man at this point
there's no way Marvel's just gonna be
like wow we don't want the rights to him
he's done he's like their biggest
selling comic that's why spider-man has
like five books have you guys seen
Avengers whatever it's called the new
book that's like said in the six that
said in the movie universe it's called
like a
as extreme or Avengers whatever it's
it's the new title worth so it's all the
movie Avengers that are in a veteran
Ultron that are in the new movie the
sequel plus spider-man and not Miles
Morales spider I'm kind of worried about
buying that because like I line it yeah
I read like I know the movie audience
like like there was one it was like it
was a black widow
it's hide Black Widow and to like with
comic books you know and then like fills
in the blanks it was terrible
like like a lot of the things like the
only the only character they've actually
done anything pretty decent with was
Phil Coulson like he's coming down are
you telling me you didn't like to find
out where rody was while they were
eating shwarma what war machine was
doing I don't give a care I don't care
about war machine but like that's that's
what I liked about I feel closer because
he was so mysterious I mean they made
him specifically for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and I don't think
Phil Coulson was ever supposed to
explode a popularity the way he did they
were let's just use him the segue into
shield and people were like oh my god I
wasn't like that was the end of it but
it was everyone like oh my god he's
still alive you know one did it it's the
fact that they made him a fan he meets
Kamala Khan and Kamala Khan is a giant
nerd - and you think that oh these guys
are gonna be best buds right away but no
they're they have like nerdy arguments
with one another like they can't stand
each other because I'm like okay that's
cool yeah that's the realest thing
you'll ever see in a comic oh that's so
real that kind of hurts and come on come
on I add min certain superhero form I
gotta read though I haven't seen that
one yet
the shield stories weren't too bad I
mean I like the stories of what was a
battle scars the worry it was like
Hammond and Marcus like Nick Fury jr.
there's another merging by the way that
right out the window I mean that's I
mean obviously like Nick
he's gone like since original sin he's
just sitting on the moon watching
everything go down so you know he's
gonna come back like like if like this
battle world's gonna happen and we're
gonna be like here's chain beyonder like
watcher version of it all original sin
was such a dud I think they're gonna be
like numb on original sin was decent
enough but the only cool thing that
happened was like everybody's secrets
got exposed that was it
which is like who cares what secrets I
mean that was really secret a new spider
character a thousand spider character
they definitely played a little weird
with what constitutes a secret whoa with
like thoughts like oh [ __ ] I had a
sister I didn't know I had oh wow yeah
well my dad might have hit my mom one
time
oh no way she didn't okay cool yeah
silly memories so did the Beyonder does
not get that was he like oh whoa that's
weird
like my favorite though was the original
set of lockjaw
well I don't know what the sin was you
just remembered where the bone was at on
the moon my greatest sin I mean I
actually kind of liked original sin cuz
we both really liked Jason Aaron and the
fact that it's like wow here's a marvel
of en't that's like not big universe and
comes it's actually quite small in
person which is the exact opposite of
what acts don't like killing people got
on me for grading access so high but I
loved ativan I love the inversion I love
seeing characters you know alter I
understand why people hate it but I'm
like for me does what I wanted to you
know yeah I agree with you on that one
Jason they got that I do my channel with
his argument wise well he likes to see
organic switches over he didn't like the
fact that they just turned the switch
right gosh I don't make it like that
that makes it okay because that made
then they can go just insane and you're
not like oh my god they're getting more
evil into 20 issues for the New Avengers
that are bad I think that that was
Marvel kind of responding to like the
whole Millar Civil War thing where
people hated the idea that they turned
their favorite heroes into jerks
yeah to it this they're like okay well
magic flip switch now they get to be
jerks and now they get to fight each
other and we get to have a tower event
and then we'll flip the switch back yep
whenever we want except our alien
because he seems cool like this what I
love about the Iron Man switches like no
invert me back as I got a magic science
shield that protects us wives good and I
wanna and I guess havoc you got to stay
evil and Sabretooth you can be good and
just yeah whatever
they're just gonna leave it like this
until the battle world they're like well
none of that worked out revert having
evil and then he went back to hang out
with his brother Scott and his brother
Scott opens up welcomes him with open
arms like oh I love you evil inverted
brother welcome to my team and then we
never seen anything from that yeah yeah
so okay this is a great lead and then I
mean I mean I think we're already kind
of mostly discussing it but I wanted to
get your guys overall opinions on battle
world I mean we've just we've kind of
led into it with spider-verse and how
it's all happening but how do you feel
cuz I mean we're all combo channels Rob
is the biggest Marvel fan you'll ever
meet in your life because I mean he does
everything with Marvel I mean Rob Rob's
gonna just gonna he's gonna do the all
new Rob explains things like this she's
just gonna reboot into that direction I
don't know Rob's I ain't paying
attention to me I'm trying to be stupid
so I just blocked in the way abandoned
thank you rob okay yeah okay see that's
what happens you get the hammer brought
down you mess with the bull you get the
horns I mean I mean you've been kind of
quiet right now what is your overall
opinion on the the whole tear of reboot
I mean Marvel finally have anyone you
know I wasn't a fan of it when I came
into the new 52 I I guess I have to
start there cuz I was there you know
that was a crisis without calling out of
crisis cuz that final crisis so seen how
that actually made a lot of people
respect my favorite comic book character
which is Aquaman which does character
has been a laughs dawn since 2001 since
I first discovered a character existed
you know I'm glad in that aspect that I
think Marvel was going to bring a lot of
these other characters to the forefront
and maybe redesign them for more
accessibility to people because I know I
have a few friends who are excited about
certain characters like daredevil but
they don't want to pick up their now
because there's so much other stuff they
didn't know don't know if after this
they can be like whoa daredevil number
one we're gonna kind of retell his
origin quickly then we're going into
stories I could see a lot of people
picking it up just like they gave
Aquaman
chance so I have a lot of hope that this
is going to be done well without a lot
of convoluting like and once again bring
it to the new 52 like Oh Superman fresh
reboot you're gonna know exactly what
happens Superman is in his fortress we
see electric blue and red and I'm like
you didn't read Khan anything that crap
still stands I hope they don't do that
you know if it's just going streamline
the universe and make sure nothing
contradicts one another don't be like
well five years from now spider-man's
going to be in the Avengers but then
Avengers which takes place five years
from then has spider-man nowhere in
sight you know I can just make it kind
of match up put itself and in battle
world just have the conflict to be
organic I don't want to be like we're
the best it's like no we're the best
country in circles I just just have them
you know kind of organically do it don't
force someone to be bad because you want
them to be the bad guy of the story
right I guess I just want characters to
be themselves and naturally you lead to
this reboot but I don't know how they do
that obviously I'm not a smart enough
writer which is why I'm not working for
them so I was just gonna say I agree
view on the new video - I loved the new
but did you reboot because it got me to
jump onto a lot of characters though but
like they were like it's a reboot it's
reboot but everything you know has still
happened but not all of it
we're gonna pick and choose things that
you like have stayed oh but do you don't
like that okay then if that didn't but
you like that okay no I'm Green Lantern
because I own right now over 900 Green
Lantern comics since the characters come
out unless there's really interface well
Green Lantern's the same I stopped
reading like I stopped reading Green
Lantern about three years before to
reboot so the reboot star some acara I'm
gonna get back into I pick it up and
it's literally the first five pages
reference everything that I miss that
I'm like this isn't a reboot at all
that's why I like when I saw the DC
explain like I hit up in Ian's cell and
I was like okay guys like I want to do
DC explain and they're like all right
and I was like where do I start with DC
Comics and they were like nudity - done
and done and I was like okay cuz like
Benny was like just go read issues like
one through seven of Justice League and
you'll know where to go from there and I
read one through seven and I was like
this
enough like that's what I like about the
new 52 that's one of the things that I
really enjoy so far I mean obviously
they didn't apparently didn't do that
with the Green Lantern but like this is
what I think Marvel's screwing up DC
with new 52 like basically like came
back and redid the origins of a lot of
their characters so your average eater
could sit down and just start all over
again with some of these characters
marvel they're not gonna do that but
this whole battle world thing they're
not rebooting the characters they're not
resetting the continuity of Spider Man
he's still gonna have the same
continuity he always had you know Parker
is still gonna be from the 1960s where
he was bitten by a radioactive spider an
amazing fantasy the difference is that
he's just gonna have this history along
with the history of other characters on
the same world what Marvel what Marvel
really really needs to do here honestly
if they want to refresh their reader
base if they want to get people back
into reading comics again is they need
to reboot everything they need to give
people in like a point zero to start
from they need to say okay guys look
those of you guys who've been buying
comics for you know 40 years whatever it
is you're not going anywhere
like we know you're not going anywhere
like you know you'll say you are but
you're not going anywhere
yeah at that point they're
institutionalized with Marvel Comics
like they're not going anywhere
yeah they look at like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and say this is
drawing you a ton I guess what you're
essentially saying is they should have
literary Ultimates it and by that I mean
start and origins of everybody and you
know what that was the same idea I had
except what if each number one issue
right comes with a giant spreadsheet
that you wouldn't open up like three
pages right and it's like here's all the
comics spider-man is here Avengers here
Captain America here and all right if
you're reading them you have a timeline
on one each one takes place it's like
it's Captain America three years I have
a spider-man okay this makes sense right
because if they do it they have to do it
that's there's some explanation of
context of what's happening cuz the new
52 literally three issues into each
comic Detective Comics was contradicting
Batman which was contradicting the Dark
Knight saying one thing I'm gonna Joker
except this happened this happened
you're just like guys like I think they
have to streamline every just show the
lack of preparation and a lack of
planning
Marvel I think has been doing for a year
now so like if they if nothing if they
don't line up then I don't what they
were doing for the last year because you
in a ton of readers but it like you said
they didn't plan it out you know
certainly I spoke to a Scot Hanna the
guy who was writing for Green Lantern
Corps and he gives in the artwork for
and he said DC leaves alone Green
Lantern can do whatever we want
I guess that's has been the philosophy
has been and I feel the same way happen
with Batman they were like okay Scott
Snyder you're doing new 52 Batman but
detective you're just gonna do your
thing and you know Batman Incorporated
you've been doing that for a while so
just go ahead keep doing that one Grant
Morrison yeah I'm saying like the new 52
was like an injection of like a fresh
reader base for DC Comics it was them
like drawing in new people because
people could say login to start from
number one like I don't have to go in by
variety years where the stories that's
what Marvel needs because if somebody
comes to my channel and they say hey
where should I start with spider-man 60
years ago I'll give you like the top 20
stories you actually bring up a really
good point cuz I'm pretty sure you guys
get it too we get a lot of questions
about where do I start reading inserts
to figure a name here and if it's a DC
superhero my normal response is go ahead
and grab the number one from new 52 for
most of them some of them are just
stupid I'm like don't bother just don't
even you don't want them but most of
them like that and when it comes to
Marvel they're like where do I start
reading spider-man I'm like well you
could jump on the dance lot run but that
goes all the way back to the big time
and you're really good right now you
could jump on it superior but that kind
of ending everything and it gets very
convoluted as to where do you begin of
reading where do you where is your
jumping on point Wolverines horrible you
know anything from 2013 or before and
he'll be in it okay Wolverine had
somewhere in the order of like thirteen
to fourteen thousand comic book
appearances no this includes everything
from like the New Mutants when they
first showed up and what's-her-name cast
an illusion of Wolverine of the minds of
one of the henchmen of the of the
Hellfire Club but it also includes like
him being and all these different
superhero groups and stuff and being in
all the on all these different teams
like well it was no this time for
Wolverine to die
I think they're green this is and I'm
making this secret Wars is gonna happen
we aren't going to get our riverine back
Altima over he's not gonna be at we're
gonna get some other Wolverine who is
near the beginning of his timeline Thank
You scar to tell fresh Wolverine stories
I think he'll still be old I think that
they like I think if they're smart they
will it none of they're smart if they
want to keep the like the elements of
Wolverine people liked they will retcon
Wolverine like they'll just reboot
everything but Wolverine will still be
like a hundred years old and he'll be
like what they could do is keep old man
Logan and make it just a really old dude
I could see them doing that old man
Logan it's gonna be part of this battle
it's a great by the way x-men 92 is
gonna be part of the if I get rogue back
yeah it's like it's herself and his
torture there's green varieties right
I think they've proven that by bringing
all new x-men
I know was initially they're supposed to
be like hey oh this is gonna be a fun
way to tell us yeah but I think what
they've proven is we want that old girl
back yes yeah we don't want Cyclops
killing Professor X and his brother
taking over and everyone hating their
own lives and we want to plead not
vampire Jubilee there's so much x-men I
could join I probably have your three
x-men a week it's the reason I go to the
gym angry and throw weights around are
so terrible that I literally in my
reviews you could tell my spirit died
and I can we just streamlined the x-men
with this reboot and I guarantee you no
matter what I guarantee you people are
saying oh I'm not gonna buy him you're
gonna see that shiny number one and a
sweet cover and a promise of a bright
future and we're gonna buy up all them
in the variants I'm gonna have them up
on my wall and I'm gonna be shining and
then like ten months later I guarantee
with the x-men I'm gonna back here we
are again guys just drinking and that's
all new x-men I was like this is a great
time for you jump on and then
mystique showed up and she's like I've
got plans and I'm like no you don't
that's like x-men all over I'm like oh
this is like accident became a problem
just like guardians of the galaxy like
it seemed like like they had a great
initial plan and then it became a game
of what can we incorporate them into
there are some good looks like I like
the serialized nature of amazing I dug X
Factor when it was going around but it's
like beyond that it's just the Bendis
x-men books if anything gets rebooted in
this next thing I hope it does please
fix x-men please x-men please
I want to enjoy it again like we would
like when our beam and I review it it's
work at this point where it's like I got
a new on Kappa did you guys read the new
one candy did you guys read 30 no well
right okay I already own candy Avengers
I didn't read oh thank you okay well
spoiler alert guys let me destroy your
mind Eva Belle the Australian time
traveler went back in time to talk to
Charles Xavier then she brought him to
the present so Xavier is technically bad
oh no no is that really how do you then
that's how they did it it was even
better as Bendis on his Twitter's like
well don't let jerks spoil the twist for
next week's issue guys I'm like yeah
yeah that news could turn anyone into a
jerk yeah yeah see here's here's here's
what I loved about 92 x-men 19 it just
it screams the 1990s no fanny packs and
stain wash jeans couches and yeah yeah
it just yeah it just it screams the
1990s which of course as we know is the
greatest era in human history so which
is we all have to agree yeah it's the
greatest point in this is all part yep
that's the one well like the other thing
about that by the way that reveal before
you get onto your tear about the
nineties is like Secret Wars like sure
Chuck's back until secret Wars and they
and then like that never happened yeah
the Nathan he goes away again but see it
was here was a thing like like x1 of the
90s were amazing and this that's one of
things I loved about 90s Marvel Comics
is you like you have so many relevant
characters in the 90s
do you like cable was important in the
90s like it was a good middle 90s like
like cable like characters mattered like
that was Marvel's heyday was the 1990s
and I feel like Marvel's trying to get
back that was a little money that's
that's that's what I'm saying like like
that's when you had like the Age of
Apocalypse and then the angel apocalypse
happens they reboot all the titles they
do it for like six months atrial pocket
a couple of fire Adriel pocalypse ends
and then it's just like rob bills when
you gonna do age of apocalypse videos
like I love like after that everything
just tainted I don't know if maybe was
just like a lack of concern about the
writers I don't know if the writers just
didn't care about any of the stories
going after that but you had like one
maybe two good stories that came after
that and that was it like now I loved
the Messiah Complex the Messiah Wars all
that kind of stuff yeah I love those
stories yes executions I loved a lot of
those stories but those were 2,000
stories and they weren't that great not
compared to what you saw in the 90s so
funny because like I legitimately like
when mystique revealed that she was like
impersonating people within the first
six of issues of x-men that I was
reading I immediately got a flashback to
strife taking his mask off what about
all the stuff with like the evil x-men
team from the future and like and like
they bring them back a second time and
they're like no no no well they weren't
all evil it's like well young Xavier was
controlling their minds but will him in
Wolverines other son from the future
we're in it together but favorite thing
from uncanny x-men because every seven
issues we find out there's a more
powerful x-men at this point the Phoenix
force might as well just be called
nothing because it's useless compared to
all the new better x-men right now they
can literally just warp reality on them
and she's like oh I'm just gonna go
create or whenever the encana x-men are
in trouble magic just teleport
yeah we're not I've grown to hate magic
so much she should have just stayed dead
like get the legacy virus and that's the
end of you goodbye dude like I never
should have brought her back when she
died of the legacy virus is a sad issue
yeah Colossus was like oh my god no my
sister's dead I'll join the acolytes I
guess see that's that's why I see that's
why I missed the 90s so much I miss 90s
and like I missed that era in time
because like like you're right you're
right you're right about the way things
stand now I think that Marvel somehow
got it into their heads if I can have
all the technology today but like in the
1990s we had Dragonball Z all right
in the 1992 I watch the [ __ ] out of that
show like I watch that show every day
and I got so pissed because you'd be
like all right awesome
and we're starting things that came out
of the 90s ever amazing there's the
Batman animated TV show that was amazing
the Spiderman animated TV show that was
amazing and the skipping because all
right so let's talk comics
so Beckham looks like by the way we're
all anyone asking we're all only 18
we're just we're just very very unfit 18
we have one Souls for 18 years old and
we have old souls no but um but I think
that's somewhere along the line while
got into their heads that bigger is
better that like the more powerful a
person is the better they are there have
to be limits all right when the Phoenix
force first popped up it was just like
oh my God look at this like like super
crazy like this Phoenix force is
unbelievable you know when she and grey
and lost her mind
it was really really cool because you
had the x-men team that you loved but
getting torn apart by a chick that was
being replaced with a cosmic entity yeah
and so like people love that concept
people love that idea but then somewhere
along the line you had this idea where
they said okay look let's just give like
everybody the ability to conquer
everybody else like everybody like the
longer you go the more powerful people
get and so on and so forth then it gets
to a point where it's silly I guess it's
just ridiculous
yeah secondary mutations and stuff like
that you know and normal beasts human
beasts I really didn't expect that to
last I was blown away by how long cat
beast made it if you read the if you
read the latest New Avengers they
referenced that yeah mama - showing all
them and they're like by the way we
liked you better as a cat well like he
was a cat and then they turned into like
a simian thing and that's that literally
been the only other transformation they
made him a little bit worse I I am am I
am I am beside myself like because
change Marvel's like a joke like that
like nothing ever really changes and so
like when they made my cat people whirl
people over in arms oh it looks like
buting the base from the 80s and I'm
like yeah but that'll be over like any
time now never ended tell me you don't
love goth Dazzler who went from being
disco to being gothic absolutely no one
even mentioned it no-one even goes hey
desert you look a little different nope
right that's that's Dantzler
you know what nobody's old asler yeah
you know why nobody mentioned when
Dazzler changed because nobody gave a
[ __ ] yeah because no one cares about
that's right
all right just moved on you know I mean
like like Galactus made Dazzler his
Herald and nobody cared like it was mom
I would be like you know let's make her
interesting and people were like nope
don't care oh don't care no one cares
the um but I mean I don't stand with the
how powerful and you know what I will
say this because of the x-men we're
having right now and what a v10 DC we're
having the same problem like we just had
Superman Superman died we need to know
the banning yeah already did yeah he
went through the the we had on died
Tuesday um and and then in the current
version he's so powerful now that he
tore dooms day in half he then becomes
doomsday swarms Brainiac and I made the
joke in my video and everyone loves to
comment on it cuz they apparently think
DC named the name I called them super
brainy doom cuz he was doomsday Superman
with brainiacs powers yeah and it was
like like how about like this is just
getting ridiculous like whatever
happened to the day and age where Goku
is the most powerful being in all of
fiction we can all agree here that is
know and we really quick we are we we
have since you touched on Superman and
Goku should we talk about the new powers
getting new powers and a new costume and
a new costume that looks like a rejected
return of Superman alternate costume
like DC you look at Superman dark how do
we make um even stronger and indirect
hey Marvel uses century no give him
those powers let's just do that the
century yeah might as well be he can
blow up all planets now he basically
does the Goku think he's just like yeah
he's been going in that direction
because the way they've been doing it
the new Superman make that it's stupid
because they brought down his power
levels
yeah and as and as the story arcs have
been going him and Supergirl
have been losing control of that power
and it's just getting more and more yeah
that's the direction we've been going in
oh I asked you wouldn't if this issue
come out is that the new one this is
it's coming out tomorrow okay because
I've seen the cover Tory USA TODAY's
spoiled it already yeah love it when
that HAP it's great like thanks for
telling me the end of Civil War
jackass is like Thanksgiving
now so okay I mean anyway yes yes this
is Oh see I want to see a DC comic where
Superman is like fighting doomsday and
like everybody's totally eradicated like
I mean they're just like yeah I know
they did that but I'm not like in the
current day like like people just like
laying unconscious and like imagine this
sorry you got like Batman who's like
bleeding from the now if like he's dead
and like Wonder Woman's like chopped in
half or something and like like you know
Hal Jordan like Green Lantern is out for
the count like so Superman's like the
only one left and like you sitting there
like half hunched over and he's like I
don't know what else to do and then like
a voice comes from on high and it's like
make a spirit bomb and so like they say
I was really surprised about the new 52
that they didn't do like alright
everybody read Death of Superman fine
right if we can all agree it's
irrelevant at this point it's like it
did its thing and it changed comics
forever but now nobody's reading that
book and going like oh that's so good
man what happened with Blue Beetle that
story unless apparently your Snider
making the new movie is like know that
this is the story everyone really wants
to see I will take all my influence from
this in Dark Knight Returns maybe not
for a new film ok ok you're doing it
already yeah but like with new 52 why
haven't we seen like we're out why
haven't we seen but I was really hoping
we were gonna see an updated version of
The Death of Superman saga where instead
of the lame Justice League with blood
wind we have the real Justice League
where Aquaman [ __ ] doomsday and like
they could still lose and Superman has
to be the last one to fight him but like
retell it much like wouldn't it be cool
if they retold maximum carnage in like
fleeing issues with better art and
better writing with cooler characters
like wouldn't it be cool to see
revisiting some of these classic stories
with some of these better or not better
I shouldn't say better because it's not
better it's just a different time with a
different perspective different
sensibilities every
like I just feel like to tell us those
stories again like I for one would love
to see nightfall in a tissues without
being lame I thought they were doing a
Superman doomed I thought it was yeah
Superman again no they can reference it
to like remember that time you died that
was cool wasn't it I mean no I'm not
cool but you know what I mean although
your mind and like at the end of that -
they make other references to one is it
- the old 52 and like basically setting
the seeds for convergence before it even
have more votes so you are gonna bring
back the old continuity in some form
yeah we've got seven worlds that they
haven't explained what they are yet and
that's what it's gonna be yeah I love
that in the guidebook which I read this
week actually quite enjoy because it was
a fun read like oh hey all these
different universe and that's like oh
but seven blank - yeah one of them being
the one that we liked before hit okay so
we're kind of we're kind of going on
time here so guys arm-in-arm on I mean
the guy that looks like I'll come in
right now are you still there okay Arman
Arman they're plowing the snow outside
some ways connect show everything throws
on the Internet
well you came just in time because guys
why don't you for anyone who's joined us
cuz as usual you guys know how podcasts
work we get more viewers towards the end
than we do at the beginning why don't
you guys let everyone know about the
Campbell cast and whatever shows you
guys would like to promote real quick
let's just okay um so this is our main
post and main dude behind come fast um
I'm the one who says all the crap you
guys hate on and send me death threats
so feel free to go over there and do
that you know I think you're comfortable
cast we have a highly successful podcast
we're Award nominated it lost out to the
official Walking Dead cast so that's
something you know tons of subscribers
and we have a you know we have some
great shows on there comic clash which
of course we verse characters but it's
different than what other people do we
of course review just about everything
that comes out so that's one thing and
Joel what else do we have
well of course we have the main comic
book cast podcast where we practice our
very special
brand of dick joke journalism that we do
you can listen to that we have a
wrestling show that Joe runs for us
called okay now nothing beats the day of
the Hardy Boys Rock but we have people
run that for us operation to talk in
which you can listen to we have a funny
news show off topic that we run like our
mean say we review pretty much
everything that comes out every week you
can see all that stuff clash we're doing
it 2015 we wanted to do more video stuff
we wanted to work that out our means got
a Q&A series Joe has a topic series I'm
working on something called comic to
sense I also worked on a thing called
Cape Chronicles which was like an SF
debris sized look into superhero
cartoons I did about 14 episodes of
those and I haven't had time to go back
it's the hardest thing I added but you
could find all those up on the
dailymotion so those are kind of
interesting and have you considered that
maybe you have too many shows I think
like three each we do we have actually
we have thought that we've done we did
some restructuring for 2015 because you
know people just told us works like guys
you upload way too much stuff no one has
time to see all of this it's true you
don't also I think one thing people like
of since we did podcasts all our
podcasts um if you guys like those and
you want our opinion movies we do audio
commentary podcasts - so you queue up
Avengers Captain America Iron Man The
Dark Knight Rises whatever you do just
hit play and you listen to us talk about
it and usually halfway through they'll
get offensive and then towards the end
you're gonna lose your mind a bit how
are these people not in hell so because
drinking heavily is seen through and so
they go downhill very quickly to the end
were just screaming at each other yeah
it says that uh Benny looks like Matt
Parkman from years kind of does - yes
okay everyone promote your channels
they're gonna do it now
um all right so so since we're since
we're comic-book people and by virtue or
superhero people how does anybody feel
about them basically bring in heroes
back if you guys have a minute the
reborn series is what it is
see I'm afraid they're gonna screw it up
terrible because Tim Kring is coming
back and he's won the screw to the
holding up in the first place so yeah
but you know what the problem that was
they try I mean the problem with heroes
I mean we don't have too much time I'd
love to go for that will explain this
repeat the problem with here is in my
opinion is heroes came out at a bad time
lost was finally making the whole
because I mean get a think before lost
shows that carried on past two episodes
never happened Buffy was like individual
episodes and towards the end they turned
into big soul season things and heroes
came out at a weird time where that was
starting to get accepted but the network
heads were still like no no no every
episode has to make sense by itself
because somebody might not be able to
watch at all so heroes isn't that weird
funk and I have a weird feeling that Tim
Kring it like because if you remember
correctly they I remember reading some
of the original interviews heroes was
supposed to be each season was gonna be
new heroes like 21 or carry over guy
yeah it was all gonna last one season
and then they would start over but the
problem is they just got so popular yeah
like Sylar just got became stupid loud I
think that was my thing like I watched
heroes season 1 and Sylar and suddenly
I'm going to see Zuko Sylar and I
finished season 200 season 3 here Sylar
I was like can we move and no you're not
no I mean I just kind of I quit out at
this point I mean he's doing Star Trek
why the hell would he come back you
can't go back from Spock is also in
NBC's The Slap
which works like it's going to be yeah
we won't go there but I do want to say
because we have a few questions about
our thoughts and endgame guys we're not
discussing endgame because the weekly
poll incursians totally taking the name
from the from their viewers over here
they're like this is the weekly poll
incursians the weekly pulling persians
will continue next week with Aris
from variant comics where we will
discuss the latest Batman topics we're
bumping into other universes maybe in
time we'll have like a very big huge
battle world where we just have like 50
I think Joel and I said it best on
Twitter eventually it's just gonna be
everyone will be on the podcast if you
will just be walking in the background
like so since we're in an incursion
somebody has to die so who's gonna fight
and I'll tell you one for the team oh he
knows he'll be back in six months you
never you're not actually gonna
technically die you'll actually have
just been removed to a different
universe and you're just like you fought
your way back you're gonna come back
with a burly beard the world war hulk
armor and a battle axe for the next six
months guys I'm going to comic cast come
over to the comic book cast you can
review Red Hood for me and therefore you
can get more drunk and die and
oppressively you know it's gonna be
doing it to myself because oh jet
powered slave what else can I say you
know the best a drunken attempt I've
seen was a comic Drake tried to do a
drunk comics discussion or he just drank
on camera and just discussed a topic
who's just like and then I remember who
I was like that guy did this yeah you
ever seen that show on like I don't have
you guys did like drunk histories like
I've always wanted to do like a drunk
comic histories like I'm gonna explain
night of the owls but I'm gonna drink
while it is like okay so this was the
early days oh they bought some bird guys
I like the burgers were great I like
Batman like secret brother like what
during convergence when they can go so
but yeah yeah go ahead and wrap this
episode of we haven't killed anyone yet
Robin okay yeah just you guys know uh
they are are mean and Armand are
Armani's da he likes pursuits oh I do I
do I have a Captain America replica suit
from the Winter Soldier kind of student
talking about our angel Joel are for
probable cast guys go check them out
they're probably the oldest if they're
they're one of if not the oldest comical
channel on YouTube and they do cover
just about everything all right I didn't
like old physically check them out guys
I think I'm not sure about when it's
gonna happen but eventually we're
supposed to show up over on their comic
book cast and then it'll just be hectic
as all hell worlds collide the comic
story and you guys know me already at
this point Rob Marvel explained were on
his freakin channel that is sell but I
do want to take this moment to let you
guys know the weekly pull dotnet is
launching by the end of this week that
is the current plan we're gonna have
articles we're gonna have forums are
gonna have a community we're gonna have
like everything you want from a comic
book website plus all the comic book
entertainment you guys get from us so
make sure you go check that out please
the weekly pull dot net if you still
want to be a part of the project send us
an e-mail sallet TV little house calm
Robin Marvel explain calm comic story at
gmail.com I'm sorry I didn't want to go
by my own address
oh I send us an email we'll forward it
to the guy who's in charge of the
various departments we'll get it up and
running also most likely starting next
week maybe the week after we will be
simulcasting this on twitch we've
acquired twitch.tv backslash the weekly
pull we're gonna start up we're gonna
start streaming over there for the next
two weeks and then we will shift over
there you'll find the podcast on iTunes
again we actually have a guy who's gonna
be doing that it should also be on
soundcloud and we're talking with
audible the weekly pull podcast will be
everywhere very soon and then you just
can't get rid of me interrupting Rob
24/7 because it's what I do
okay with that so guys please check it
out we're working hard to get this
weapons I get the switch up and running
we're working hard to get the podcast
into more locations so you guys can
listen to it while you go to work you
can listen to it whenever you want it
you don't have to wait for us to go
Bob's channel and then don't listen to
me in the shower I don't want to know
what you do in the chat talking about
punch and pie like your first punch and
pie I want some punch making a hilarious
joke oh okay yeah I thought they were
made of a South Floyd reference I just
want to say one last thing with the we
pull that no I don't mind if you guys
interrupt me can you not do it during
the plug guys that we pulled that that
we also have two other guys on there
comicdrake and it's super effective are
joining us so make sure you go check out
their channels also thank you interrupt
all you want it's all they wanted to get
out the end anyway guys yeah I guess
we're gonna go and wrap this episode up
yeah alright guys thanks for having us
being here guys and I guess we'll see
you next time that we drag you on here
this sounds good are you we will catch
you guys later